today's video is about the classic film
akira the movie is set in japan in 1988
an explosion caused by a young boy with
psychic powers tears through the city of
tokyo and ignites the fuse that leads to
world war iii now in the year 2019 a
restored version of the city is known as
neo tokyo and with that context out of
the way let's begin the movie starts in
a shitty bar where the main character
garner is sitting by his lonesome until
one of his goons comes and informs him
that they've located one of the enemy
gang members so they step outside as the
jukebox starts playing outside we see
tetsuo dueling over garneta's bike as if
it was a redhead hottie so naturally
garnetta tells him to [ __ ] off since it
was built for a real man and it was
built for kannada thus tetsuo mounts his
generic looking bike and they ride to
glory with a sick beat playing in the
background while fighting a rival bike
gang cars get destroyed shops are
wrecked and bones are broken but nothing
of that matches as we get to witness
garner's classic drift however the
police seem unappreciative on the other
end we see a man dragging a little child
behind him while being chased by cobbs
but i am positive he's not a pedophile
as the child one looks ugly as hell two
looks older than my dad and three the
man is injured so dragging a kid for one
last walk would be redundant that said
the chase continues and the man shoots
two dogs damn haiti's anime had no chill
yet then it became more apparent that he
wasn't the bad guy when the comps gunned
him down with the kid beside him the kid
wasn't hurt due to the man body blocking
the shot and while the man takes his
last breath he tells the kid to run and
don't let them catch him seeing the man
on the floor swimming in a pool of blood
the kids start screaming destroying
every lamp on site meanwhile the boys
are still chasing the rival gang dead 20
closes in on the enemy making him crash
in the most impressive display of 80s
animation to then hit him with a hammer
and mock him saying good catch which
ironically turns onto him catching the
wrinkled little kid from earlier with
his bike a big explosion occurs however
the boy is still alive and so is tetsuo
who gets unconscious between garnet's
arms then our main man sees the kid but
he's too dumbfounded by what he's seeing
to the point that his group get caught
by surprise when the army arrives the
little kid tries to flee the scene but
another adult baby arrives and tells him
to stop running as he knows they're not
allowed to be outside the kid surrenders
and the gang gets arrested by the police
while tetsuo gets taken by the military
the next day comes and the boys are in
the police office getting questioned as
if they are in the high school
principal's office the police officer
scolds the boys and tells them to call
their mother so they can come and take
them while they wait with the rest of
the detained people garnett sees a chick
sitting between a couple of ugly
bastards he goes to her after a lunatic
escapes the interrogation room with a
grenade in his hand and screams for
revolution triggering the bomb which
turns out to be nothing but a smoke bomb
the army men catch the guy and show him
the meaning of revolution aka they beat
the [ __ ] out of him yet not all the
things are bad and negative in that
scene as our boy kaneda manages to get
to the girl amid all of that chaos he
then tells the police officer that the
girl is a part of their group and that
she was with them last night at this
point the policemen are too annoyed to
question it and just tell them to [ __ ]
off and take the girl with him so now
outside the station garner tries to put
the moves on a chick that looks like his
half-sister or something like that to
which she's not that interested
especially after seeing a shady figure
between the crowd hence she leaves our
boy ghana to drive speaking about boys
we finally get to see how tetsuo is
doing and from the looks of it he's not
doing that good don't know if you
guessed it but all the machines attached
to him that's not a good sign is it an
einstein looking fella with a white coat
remarks that tetsuo's aura resamples
nothing they have seen before due to his
crash with number 26 aka the wrinkled
kid the colonel asks if the doctor
started the compression with the akira
pattern thus einstein does it on the
spot after seeing the results he
concludes that tetsuo aura might be a
clue to untangling the mystery of akira
the colonel encourages him however when
einstein declares his intention of using
the center hues from level seven the
colonel says ah fine but if you can't
control it stop and get rid of it
fast forward and we see the boys getting
shouted at by the principal of a run
down high school but what's really funny
is the coach who b-slapped garnetta and
the group so hard that they walked out
the office with swelling cheeks outside
they get approached by a couple of
skanks one of the girls asks about
tetsuo the group tells that he gets
caught by the army she gets sad and then
leaves the group fast forward at night
and a runaway tetsuo makes his way to
the girl and he tells her to go to
somewhere far and by stealing his
friend's bike they ride to a peaceful
end however the journey is cut short as
the bike stops working and they get
caught by the rival gang from earlier
one douche hits tetsuo's gf then they do
something to her that i can't show on
youtube okay meanwhile the rest of the
gang pins tetsuo to the ground as the
main douchebag lights up a rag but just
when he's about to throw it the boys
arrive on the scene and garnetta jumps
off his buddy bike in the coldest
fashion drop kicking the neanderthal
saving the day now although the day was
saved tetsuo's not in the mood he beats
the living hell out of the low-life
lackey to the point garnett says look
that's enough now however tetsuo doesn't
take too nicely to it telling canada to
f off and leave him alone since he
thinks the group preserves him as a
loser because he's smaller than them
hashtag insecure much anyways tetsuo
suddenly starts hearing voices inside
his head and while the reality is
shattered for him the voices keep saying
akira akira tetsuo starts screaming due
to the immense pain in his head leading
einstein to send a force to grab him
before he loses control
night falls and we see ghana and the
boys hanging out peacefully this time
with no problems until an explosion
rocks the area garner noticed the girl
he helped earlier in the police station
running out of the area along with a
middle aged man they're being chased by
the police the girl and the man split at
the underground tunnels however she's
still being chased by the cops and
although she manages to escape the first
time by pulling a gun she gets cornered
the second time with no way out until a
boy canada comes to the rescue knocking
one guy out cold creating an opening for
her to shoot the other guy right in the
eye and to escape with the lover boy
meanwhile on the other side tetsuya was
having one of the worst nightmares i've
ever seen it was so bad he woke up and
shouted garnetta destroying the glass
above his head that said he wasn't the
only person having a bad dream as we get
introduced to a little old girl with a
number 25 on her hand describing the
same dream to the colonel she tells him
in her dream akira came back the city
was getting destroyed because of a boy
and then she fainted soon after we
learned that these dreams are more than
normal dreams as einstein says these are
more like precognition and foresight
with this info they go to the unknown
location underground where it's cold but
it's not freezing where garnet is at on
the contrary it's boiling with pressure
where k took our boy as he almost got
shot not once but twice first was for
following his heart second was for
following curiosity as he was
eavesdropping from a vent he told the
shady group that the new test subject
thereafter is his friend and he's
worried about him that's why he's
eavesdropping not because he's a spy for
the government and i guess it works
since after the scene faded at gunpoint
we see the middle-aged man telling an
old geezer the boy might be useful later
on since he's so close to the test
subject the old geezer tells him to be
cautious of the kid and continues to
narrate while strolling the open filthy
streets of neo tokyo and points to a
group of nutjob monks burning stuff and
basically shouting since bad culture
overrated military bad akira are good
our gear are coming soon of course the
first responders didn't take too nicely
to such claims and they shut down these
nut jobs meanwhile on the other end of
the spectrum we see a bunch of old men
gathering these are the government
officials of neo tokyo and they're
currently discussing what to do in the
face of the increasing activities of
anti-activists and whether they should
finance the experiments on number 25.
this leads to a conflict in a meeting as
some don't believe in akira and some do
but would rather put the money on other
projects soon after we get back to
tetsuo who wakes up inside a hospital
and god damn i wish i wasn't eating
while watching this scene i mean it's
not like the hallucination was super
disgusting but the music and spectacle
of it made me distracted dropping
mayonnaise on my jacket but as i hear
you say who [ __ ] cares continue the
recap man i've got places to be so as
tetsuo apparently as he whimpered out of
the room to be approached by a doctor
the doctor was nice and all but sadly it
didn't matter tetsuo pulverized him
along with the security men then the
scene is cut to the underground where
canada kay and the rest of the
revolution are they were using the
sewage system to get to the upper floors
of the building all was going according
to plan until a security man spots them
with his flying motorcycle the guy
ordered back up and the pursuit began k
manages to gun down one motorcycle but
gets stuck behind looking for her gun so
as usual ganetta comes to the rescue he
knocks one guy and takes his flying
motorcycle and goes back to picking k up
together they fly through the
underground center tunnel making their
way to tetsuo who we learned from the
radio on the cycle that he managed to
escape to the upper floors and when we
get to see him again we see a more
powerful version of tetsuo facing the
soldiers and killing them after killing
them he gets to the floor where the
little kids are they try using the old
hallucination tactic but it's proven
useless so they knock tetsuo to the wall
and run for it meanwhile ganada is still
heading to their location and they get
some direction from the little girl
however she gets cut by the two kids and
dead so who closes in on them they tried
to fight with them but yet again to no
avail the colonel arrives on the scene
along with soldiers and things calm down
a little bit till the little girl
mentions the name akira needless to say
it was a big mistake that started [ __ ]
up yet again thankfully canada and kay
arrive to the now destroyed floor a boy
urges tetsuo to hurry up and get moving
so they can escape before the soldiers
arrive however when the soldiers reach
the entrance tetsuo sends them flying
with his new powers along with ganada as
a side casualty detour starts laughing
maniacally as he tells ghana that he
doesn't need his help anymore he's the
big dog now and he's the new king canada
like the alpha stands up despite
tetsuo's new godlike powers which
obviously turns to be a big mistake but
before tetsuya goes any further he gets
stopped by the little girl and from her
he learns the location of akira and goes
flying to him after the colonel checks
on the remaining survivors he orders a
reinforcement to the olympic stadium
where archeolo is supposedly located he
also issues an order to detain all the
high-ranking officers after a military
police investigator tries taking him to
prison meanwhile tetsuo goes back to the
run-down bar where the movie started and
the bartender tries to check up on him
however tetsuo is just too cool to say
look yeah man i'm good thanks for asking
instead he orders him to bring the good
stuff the bartender tells him okay but
the price is now higher than before and
the camera cuts to the other boys who
are left with no camera time till now
they enter the truly run down bar to
find the bartender dead and then they
hear a laughing voice it's tetsuo doing
the itachi pose in darkness the boys ask
what happened there he says he got
carried away and that gane descends his
regards implying that he's dead so one
guy gets angry and when he tries to act
up and put tetsuo back in his place he
gets brutally reminded why he's the side
character that said we find out the king
of swag is still alive and kicking also
we kind of find out who akira is thanks
to kaye's national geographic lesson
long story short akira is a young orphan
child recruited by the government for
their secret parapsychology project
akira's powers grew rapidly eventually
beyond his control destroying the
original tokyo that led to world war iii
suddenly the little girl takes control
of kaye's body and continues the history
lesson for a bit then opens the door
setting the couple free from the prison
cell that they're being kept in outside
we see tanks helicopters cops and
soldiers all operating together on the
ground near the bar where we see kaizuke
is still alive he gets caught up with
the couple and informs kanedo what
tetsuo had done to their friends and
tells him that he asked for his bike so
canada did the only cool thing he could
do he mounted tetsuo's bike and with a
tear in his eye he drove that poor girl
into a wall destroying it but then the
mood changes as number 26 approaches kay
slowly and takes her with him garnier
tries to stop them but failed the little
girl tells him that the power of akira
is in everyone and it could be awakened
in anyone whether they're good bad or
not ready just like what happened to
tetsuo meanwhile massive run behind
tetsuo who arrived earlier in fashion of
course and destroyed tanks with his
telekinesis powers and continued
marching forward to the stadium
before he arrived he gets cut yet again
by the army this time they bring laser
guns they shoot but the shots go too
wide killing the people behind him and
at this moment i thought he carried for
the religious nut job following him but
i guess i was wrong yet again as he
destroys the bridge with no regards of
the people behind him killing everyone
one thing though i'm glad that the old
monk died because god that dude was so
annoying anyway he finally arrives to
the gate of the stadium with a smug look
on his face where a small platoon
protecting the gate awaits but he
dismantles them and proceeded to go
underground where he found kaye who i
believe is still being controlled by the
espa's kids she tells him if he
continues using his powers the way he's
using them he'll eventually lose control
and of course a kid with a god complex
wouldn't listen having no other option
than violence as such k sends him flying
to a wall however he stands back up
impressed and thus the battle begins in
front of the colonel and gun at his eyes
tetsuya wins the fight and goes to open
the akira capsule to find nothing but
body parts in it the kernel tells him
that akira has been dead all along and
these parts are what are left of him for
future generations to study and solve we
then see kaneda riding to tetsuo they
exchanged some words and memories from
old time's sake before they throw down
and apparently all that it took to bring
tetsuo down was one man with a laser gun
and swag as well as a space station
cannon that cuts off one of tetsuo's
arms and makes him angry to the point
that he flew to outer space and
destroyed the station by sending it
towards the sun which consequently saved
kaneda k and kaizuke without him knowing
fast forward and we see tetsuo's gf
walking in the olympic stadium she hears
tetsuo in pain and helps him to his
throne then she notices his new arm
tetsuo tells her to leave him as his arm
starts molesting the chair subsequently
the colonel arrives on the scene and we
learn through him and einstein that he's
losing control since the medicine is
wearing off so he urges tetsuo to head
back to the lab with him but tetsuo
refuses and pushes him away in return
the colonel shoots him when he tries to
reach his girlfriend on the floor tetsuo
extends his arm devouring the colonel he
gets stopped by none other than the man
himself garnett shoots multiple times at
him but tetsuo shuts him down by
destroying the ground beneath him then
throw the rocks at him and right when it
looked grim for one second the espa's
kids arrive and number 26 takashi saves
ganada then they go to akira's body
parts as tetsuo loses control and starts
morphing into the famous big ugly infant
devouring both ganada as well as his
girlfriend who dies from the pressure
while garnetta lacks out as he's being
mushed in what i assume a soft place
then as the colonel's time comes and
getting devoured he tells the kids to go
somewhere safe belittle did he know the
glass jars will break and akira will
manifest suppressing tetsuo's aura a bit
for them to save the colonel and canada
who instead of running decides to go and
save his friend again a bit of a stupid
decision on garnet's behalf there
leaving little takashi aka number 26
with no other choice than going in and
saving the dumb lad now inside the white
hole we see the characters witnessing
each other's memories from ghana and
tetsuo's childhood memories to the
espa's kids memories when they used to
be experimented on then the flashbacks
cut to canada who's being thrown into an
entirely new reality as the city is
getting destroyed or as the doctor puts
it rebirth we get to see a sick view of
the city from a higher point of
perspective to then cut to k who is
calling for canada and just when i
presumed he was a goner the writer pulls
yet another twist
and reveals that he's still alive he
thanks kay for calling his name out and
they ride along with kaisuke to a new
tokyo the end i hope you enjoyed the
recap of this film as by far it's one of
the longest we've done and due to the
size of the actual film a number of
events happening at the same time we
tried to keep it short and simple as
much as we could or it wouldn't even be
a recap anymore with that said i really
hope you like and subscribe as we've had
a great time doing this one that's about
it see you in the next one